[Musique]
ce samedi 15 avril a été organisé une
matinée de valorisation de l'action web
week-end parentalité au village de
corail un dispositif mis en place par le
Département 2020 à l'issue du
confinement qui offre des familles
fragilisées un séjour de deux nuits dans
une structure de loisirs un week-end qui
est aliments de convivialité et atelier
d'accompagnement à la parentalité
la famille et certainement le bien le
plus précieux que nous avons et que nous
devons que nous avons reçu en héritage
que nous devons préserver absolument et
le département s'emploie à faire en
sorte que cette parentalité soit
d'excellence et le week-end parentalité
est un de ces
dispositifs que le département mis en
place pour aider les familles les plus
en difficulté à pouvoir avoir justement
la chance de vivre des moments de
partage et sûrement comme on l'a dit
d'oxygénation
qui nécessaire nous vivons au quotidien
une vie particulièrement difficile avec
beaucoup de tension beaucoup de stress
et
là sur un moment comme ça beaucoup de
commentaires convivialité les familles
sont heureuses et nous aussi
cette action s'inscrit dans le
dispositif de stratégie nationale de
prévention et de lutte contre la
pauvreté
comme on l'appelle
est un
d'une manne financière de l'État qui
vient contractualiser avec le
département pour la mise en œuvre d'un
certain nombre d'actions sur des axes
bien précis sur l'insertion sur l'action
sociale la démarche d'aller vers l'accès
au droit le et la parentalité et donc
les week-ends
une véritable bouffée d'oxygène pour les
familles présentes
pour nous il change parce que nous en
apporte-moi et nous a pas la possibilité
de sortir souvent et du coup pour les
marma il est super vous êtes la piscine
la plage et surtout être en famille
ce week-end si surtout moi eu la
possibilité d'emmener tous mes enfants
avec moi et
ça allait bien il fait plaisir de voir à
tous ses enfants rien qu'on passe son
temps qu'on voit tous les enfants à
table
on voit les petits-enfants contents et
ça il fait chaud au cœur
un dispositif qui monte en puissance
entre juillet et décembre 2020 193
familles ont bénéficié de cette mesure
de solidarité de juillet 2022 à février
2023 se sont 380 familles qui en ont
bénéficié
[Musique]